michelle is up next in north carolina
hi Michelle how are you hi Dave I'm
doing great how are you better than I
deserve what's up it's a privilege to
talk to you um so I have a vehicle with
my now ex-husband and I have the money
to pay it off however he will not sign
over any of his rights
towards it if I decide to resell it I
don't plan on doing that in the near
future but in the event that I need to
in the future I would like to have that
ability I'm sorry I'm sorry what are the
divorce decree say was it happens with
this car um it didn't have we didn't
discuss vehicles I mean it's just in my
name I mean I am fully responsible no no
it's in his name he owns the car you
don't own the car yeah it's in both of
our names right now okay yeah and so
what I would do is tell him apparently
he gave you this car in the divorce
right but nobody was smart enough to
ride it into the divorce decree yeah
they're just kind of he has a motorcycle
and I have the car so that's how it
worked out okay does is your name on the
motorcycle it it okay so I would explain
it to him this way either I'm gonna hire
an attorney and drag your ugly butt back
to court and we're gonna get these names
off of these vehicles because everybody
that took this divorce to start with was
stupid because you guys did not address
this in a divorce decree whoever your
attorney was should have their butt
kicked okay
and we're either gonna go back into
court and the judge is gonna tell you to
take your name off of my car and my name
off of your motorcycle or we're gonna do
that voluntarily now do you want to this
the hard way or the easy way you cannot
pay off a car or you've got a goob
sitting off in the distance with his
name on your car and won't release it
yeah so I was gonna just refinance it
into my name you can't refinance the
title into your name you talked about
the loan has both names on it or the
title what the loan has
whose name is the title in both yeah and
that's what he needs to sign over yeah
so even if I refinance he would still
have to find something yeah hey there's
the ownership and then there's the death
or two different things
yeah the car title out and figure out
whose name is on the car title and then
get his name off of the car title and
then pay the loan off and that's what
you've got to do and he either do it the
hard way or the easy way but this should
have been done in the divorce decree
this should have already been handled
but you guys are got to go clean it up
now and he's standing over there acting
like he's got rights or something give
me a break